first reaction miles when when you heard
that it was done for carson wentz
finally in philadelphia
well uh my first reaction probably was i
guess now we know what coming days means
right i mean we heard it think it was
super bowl sunday that he was supposed
to be traded in the coming days so i
guess coming days can be anywhere from
one to ten days uh if you really want to
trade and hearing that sound from howie
roseman is just striking man he's like
fingers on your hand i guess you just
cut a couple of them off right or
something and i don't know which finger
it is but maybe carson once wanted to
give a particular finger to the eagles
at some point in this whole saga
last night we played that sound on pftpm
and i made a jpp joke on the way in
simply because leonard fournette did it
after the buccaneers parade so once that
bridge is crossed it's fair game with
the
eagles or jpp this morning jokes because
they are they cut the finger off their
hand and they move on to jalen hurts
plus whoever we're going to break that
trade down from both perspective eagles
and cults and other relevant
developments as it relates to that trade
or not trade to the chicago bears but
let's start with the philadelphia eagles
they get a third round pick in 2021
plus a second round pick in 2022 that
can upgrade to a first rounder if
carson wentz takes 75 percent of the
snaps or 70 plus they make the playoffs
that creates a strange incentive to
bench him near the end of a season that
may be lost for the indianapolis colts
but
look that that's an issue for farther
down the road for now the eagles get
something for a contract they wanted to
dump that's good news for the eagles
this had the feel of a brock osweiler
trade this had the feel of a jared goff
let's work him into the matthew stafford
trade so no one notices that we're
actually giving something up to get this
contract off our books when you consider
that the eagles were stuck with a
horrible contract miles the fact that
they got anything is a miracle
even though they fell short of that
first round pick in 2021 that they were
hoping to get they may end up with one
come 20 22.
yeah they were never going to get that
matthew stafford package that was
reported that they wanted i mean because
in part like you just said
jared goff had to be part of that deal
and they had in the rams had to give a
first round pick just to get rid of
jared goff so it's not like really they
were trading for matthew stafford for
all of that and i think sometimes people
forget that but because of that and you
look at what carson wentz did last year
i think the fact that they got even a
three and a two for him is kind of
incredible because look he was not a
good quarterback and so from that
perspective when you get something for
somebody who is so bad and then you also
get to unload that contract i think that
makes it an automatic win for the eagles
and the eagles were fortunate that there
was a team out there where the planets
lined up there's a colts team that
desperately needed a quarterback given
the retirement of philip rivers and this
this merry-go-round they've been on
since andrew luck abruptly retired in
august of 2019 and frank reich is there
as the head coach and frank reich has
the relationship with carson wentz and
the eagles spin on the 2020 regression
of carson wentz that it's no different
than ben roethlisberger in 2006 it's no
different than peyton manning in 2001.
both of those guys rebounded from it
that spin has a chance of working on
frank reich because he's got the
relationship he knows carson wentz and
he can believe yeah this was just a blip
on the radar screen and we're actually
lucky to be
getting him at a spot where we can do it
for a three and a two that may become a
one if he had played in 2020 like he had
in 2019 there's no way we get this deal
and that's you know the point i made
yesterday if you tell a colts fan last
year at this time
you're going to get philip rivers for
one year at 25 million and then you're
gonna have carson wentz at 25.4 million
they'd sign up for that in a heartbeat
they'd say why can't we just get carson
wentz right now
so uh
the the the fact that they found
a suitor who was the only suitor that
ever made sense but the fact they found
one
and they were able to just be patient
wait until they had what was the best
offer there was a report from wednesday
from zach kiefer of the athletic that
the colts weren't budging once the
eagles realized that the colts were at
their bottom line that the colts were
not going to throw another draft pick or
upgrade the three this year to a two or
whatever it was they weren't going to
make an improvement to their offer may
as well just do it be done with it have
this coming days end
before we get to march 17 because i was
at the point where i thought well
there's nothing more to do
let's just wait until we get to the
point where the new league year is
beginning and do the deal then so that
kind of surprised me because it felt
like both sides were going to stay
locked in until they moved toward their
bottom line the colts i think convinced
the eagles we ain't moving and so the
eagles decided we just need to be done
with this
yeah and i think that's kind of the
discipline of chris ballard he just
seems to be that kind of guy where he
has a plan and he's going to stick to it
and in some of these gm's across the
league they sometimes give off the
impression that they have a plan and but
you know really behind the scenes
they're thinking all right well we can
tell them this but then at the end of
the day yeah we can go up or we can go
down or we can do whatever to make this
really work i think that because of
chris beller's reputation as somebody
who's like look i'm straight shooter man
this is the only thing we're going to do
and we know from the years past they're
not just going to give up draft picks
willy-nilly that's just not the way they
operate there in indianapolis and so
because of that i think the eagles just
finally figured out look we really don't
have many other options here and i don't
think we're going to get a better offer
and you know maybe you want to do right
by carson wins maybe you don't i don't
necessarily know what they're thinking
in terms of that but this is really the
only good situation i think that carson
wentz could be placed in where he may
actually be able to thrive in this
particular offense with this particular
coach mike so i think that from that
perspective yeah this was kind of the
only way that this could turn out
i think that the notion of doing right
by carson wentz was superseded by the
notion of doing what's right for the
eagles and the eagles realized the best
interests of the organization were
served by finding a way to get a
disgruntled quarterback off of the
roster he didn't want to be there it was
clear he didn't want to be there even
after they fired doug peterson there was
the reporting from espn that the
relationship between wence and peterson
had become fractured fine peterson's
gone oh wait that's not good enough we
still need to trade carson white because
i really do believe the eagles were
hoping to find a way to work this out
and to go forward with wentz and hertz
and make a decision at some point
between now and week one who the better
option would be wence i don't think
wanted that wence
wants to play wence believes he's earned
it wence believes he's entitled to it
and if we go back to the draft from last
april when they took jalen hurts with a
second round pick
that according to jay glazer of fox he
reported that in one of the various
sundays of the 2020 season that caused
wence to lose confidence that caused
wence to slip into a funk from which
he never recovered and what a contrast
between what the eagles did with hertz
what the packers did with aaron rodgers
in drafting jordan love
it worked on aaron rodgers he
skyrocketed
and carson wentz by all appearances went
the other way one of the reasons that
carson once struggled he
had an offensive line that had 14
different combinations due to injury
he's going to indianapolis where the
offensive line is much better so this
could work out extremely well for carson
wentz personally but it had been an ugly
year and it just shows you how quickly
in today's nfl what we thought was a
long-term relationship can fall apart
and we never would have guessed this
that doug peterson would be out and the
carson wentz would be gone a year ago
unfathomable that something like this
would happen but when something like
this does happen miles
what it does and and this may be a bad
thing
it encourages me to always be looking
for the possibility that something else
like this can happen somewhere else and
it's the kind of thing when you start
spitballing on potential calamities for
franchise quarterbacks and teams the fan
bases start yelling and screaming and
shouting
all i have to point to is look what
happened with carson wentz you can't
rule anything out in this crazy business
well it's it's the same sort of thing
you could talk about i think with the
rams and with jared goff right although
this this makes you sound like a very
dark human being mike but at the same
time i think that when you see these
things
across the league well i guess i don't i
just started working here you know
but when you see these things go out
across the league right i think what you
have to think about is there are
consequences of playing poorly that can
come within you know a season of
something else where you just thought
man they are on the long term track and
i think when you look at what happened
with 2016 where both teams trade up you
get one and two with the rams and eagles
and jared goff and carson wentz i don't
think even a year ago maybe even six
months ago we would have been thinking
oh my gosh these guys are both going to
be shipped out of the teams that have
drafted them because of their poor
performances in 2020. it's just the
weird nature of this business and
especially when you're talking about the
quarterback position things can really
change in a hurry mike and i i just i
think you're right to say look the next
calamity can be just around the corner
and
i i am fascinated by
the two back-to-back drafts 2015-2016
jameis winston the first pick by the
buccaneers marcus mariota the second
overall pick by the titans they worked
for the teams for five years each full
contract with the option year
and then were gone that was it their
teams held firm and didn't give them a
second contract
2016 rams trade up eagles trade up after
three seasons both jared goff
and carson wentz get long-term contracts
and by the time they had finished their
fifth seasons
both teams were ready to move on
cautionary tale
for other teams
that have a first round quarterback that
they can keep for up to five years that
option year is a powerful tool
to allow you to wait and see
are you sure you'll want to do this
because maybe you will decide after that
fifth year it's time to move on and you
don't want to be caught in a contract
that causes you to not get what you
could or
to to give up
more
than you'd like to get that contract off
your books and it makes me wonder
when they do their planning sessions
with the teams and they get together and
they talk about contract structures and
philosophies
that there is reason to be patient there
is reason to wait cleveland browns i'm
talking to you with baker mayfield don't
rush in to a contract with baker
mayfield after only three seasons
lamar jackson and the ravens
they've made it clear they want to do it
and maybe they think they can do a very
team friendly deal because lamar jackson
doesn't have an agent and and you can
get him to see it your way and you can
maybe get him to do a deal that you
can't say no to you never know what's
going to happen over the course of the
next two years even josh allen and the
bills although we're sold right now
we were sold on carson wentz after three
years it just it shows you how quickly
things can change and
that once you commit that money and once
you put yourself in that cap predicament
where the dollars are there and you've
got to pay them and and even if you do
trade the guy and save the money you're
taking a major cap hit these are all
things that need to be considered when
deciding to sign a quarterback to a
second contract
and and i think when teams trade up
they're more likely to do it miles i
think that's what makes them inclined to
let the whole world know we got it right
we rolled the dice we moved up and this
contract tells the world we were right
yeah you know it's not like you trade up
in order to get that guy and then you
want to let him go
five years later but i think what you're
saying about these guys in this 2018
draft class is particularly interesting
because this is gonna come up now over
the next i don't know maybe a few weeks
to the next coming months because these
guys are now eligible for these contract
extensions so i think you're right this
is kind of a cautionary tale maybe for
both the the browns the ravens
the bills i mean the jets have sam
darnold and he was also a part of that
draft class but who knows what's going
to happen there i think you're right the
fifth year option is a powerful tool and
really the only thing that these teams
are maybe going to lose if they don't
sign these guys right now
is that you're going to lose a little
bit of financial flexibility perhaps in
the later years because the only thing
that these quarterback contracts do is
go up that's just the way the market
works so even when jared goff signed his
extension you know a year ago and i got
rams fans in my tweets saying oh what do
you think of this it's like well
if you want to keep this guy then this
is the going rate for quarterbacks this
is just what the market rate is so if
you're the bills if you're the browns if
you're the ravens you got to know that
the only thing these contract
quarterbacks or his quarterback
contracts excuse me you're going to do
is continue to go up but if you're
winning who cares you have your
quarterback you have your guy and to me
that's the most important thing mike
and i am fully aware of the fact that in
the past i've said when you draft a
quarterback the moment you know he is
your guy you get him signed the
cautionary tale on the other side is the
cowboys constantly delaying and waiting
and not signing dak prescott and it gets
more and more and more expensive all the
time because he
since he wasn't a first-round pick
four-year rookie contract
franchise tag and now they're staring at
second tag at
37.68 million because they went
exclusive tag last year which was 31.4
if they had gone non-exclusive tag and
risked the possibility of someone
signing into an offer sheet and they
would have gotten two first-round picks
they didn't want to do that with the
highest possible tag you add 20 on to
that this year and if you don't work out
a long-term deal with them you add 44 on
to it next year they have gotten
themselves into a mess
because they didn't
rush in at the right moment and get the
deal done
but the flip side of that coin is
if you do you better be damned sure just
make sure you are damn sure before you
do it the problem is
the eagles
i suspect were the rams i don't think
were i think the rams did it because
they felt like they had to do it because
people like me were saying you shouldn't
do it people like me were saying he
missed a throw in super bowl 53 that
would have potentially won the game is
he really a championship quarterback is
he really the guy that you want for the
next 15 years and i almost feel like
they got pushed into it by all the talk
and it wasn't just me it was others
saying don't do it don't do it i think
the attitude at some level was show you
we're gonna do it we know what's right
for this team and then two years later
what's right for the team is to is to do
the brock osweiler hot potato and get
him out of town it just it it just shows
you how the nfl has become
such a year to year proposition every
team is different every year is
different the circumstances every year
are different and what the team did in
the most recent season carries so much
more weight than anything that the team
or the player had ever done before
that's the reality that a lot of these
teams now find themselves in
well i think it's also progress versus
regress right and if you look at both
jared goff and carson wentz progress was
not being made you know carson wentz's
best year and what people keep turning
back to i think is 2017. now he did have
some good moments last year you know and
then he led that team to the playoffs
before he was knocked out in the first
half of that game against the yeah 2019
miles 2019 he was all they had 2019 they
were five and seven and it was carson
wentz and a bunch of guys of whom i'd
had to know who of whom let me try that
again a bunch of guys i had to google to
find out who the hell they were so that
that's what it became near the end of
the season he really was solid in 2019
and 2018 until he had the back injury
look look at that in 27 and seven in
2019 21 touchdown passes and seven picks
in 2018 of course he was phenomenal in
2017 so the body of work was there
that's what makes last year so damn
confusing and that's why the eagles
thought it was a fluke they thought it
was an aberration and and they may find
out the hard way that they were right
because let me tell you this if carson
wentz goes to indy and he goes back to
that 33-7 split and he's an mvp
candidate you think the eagles fans who
would have been pissed off sorry london
if they had kept carson wentz you think
they're going to be
forgiving you think they're going to
forget you think they're going to say to
the eagles it's okay that you traded him
we didn't know he was going to be good
again we we still liked him we didn't
give him another chance baloney so
that's the worst possible outcome you
know the good news is the eagles they
get the pick upgraded to a first rounder
for 2022. the bad news is they're never
gonna hear the end of it if carson wentz
becomes
next year who he was every year before
2020.
yeah but
i just feel like when you saw what he
was doing this year man like i and i
know that the eagles skill position
players
even this year right but the offensive
line had to go through so many different
combinations but at the same time when
you're taking 50 sacks and you're
getting sacked four times a game and
deshawn watson is you know has 49 sacks
and he's getting 16 games and he's only
getting sacked three times a game some
of that's on the qb and i think when
you're not getting rid of the ball and
the timing and rhythm of the play and
you're not seeing things properly it's
hard to then say all right everything is
going to go back to the way it was the
year before is it just a confidence
thing i don't know i mean is it because
now frank wragg and everybody in
indianapolis wants him that he's all of
a sudden magically gonna get his
confidence back i don't i don't know how
much i believe in that i really don't i
mean i don't think that carson wins is a
lost cause by any means but i think to
say that he's going to get back to an
mvp level just because he gets a change
of scenery and just because he goes to a
colts team that has a much better
offensive line and granted they still
got to figure out their left tackle
situation fonzo retired so that's
another thing that i think they're
really going to have to figure out and
say all right this is actually going to
be the best plan for carson wentz i
think he's in a much better situation
but i i count me as one of the skeptics
that he's going to get back to an mvp
look at the difference in pass block
efficiency via pro football focus for
the colts and the eagles last year but
you're right they have to replace
anthony costanzo there's been some talk
about possibly moving quentin nelson out
to tackle that we had a post uh with joe
thomas remarks about how difficult that
will be for nelson and also it creates a
hole in the middle of a line if you do
that who do you replace nelson with if
you slide him out to tackle so
uh i i hear what you're saying and and
trust me something went wrong last year
and
i'd like to think that frank reich
was able to
get on the phone with doug peterson
get on the phone with whoever he need to
get on the phone with he's got press
taylor working for him now in
indianapolis you got a way to get to the
bottom and make your judgment and maybe
it's impossible to diagnose with
certainty but why did carson wentz
go sideways last year and and at some
point
the eagles may have authorized a
conversation between wentz and reich
directly yes it would be tampering for
reich to call up wentz and say let's
talk about what happened last year if
the eagles say it's okay it's not
and and if the cults say hey look we'll
do this dance with you but one of the
things we got to figure out is whether
or not you're right when you say it was
an aberration so let us get on the phone
with carson wentz and try to get to the
bottom of this so the fact that the
colts did it
tells me that the cults
did their homework they did their due
diligence and they have come to the
the conclusion
imperfect as it may be
time will tell performance will show
whether or not they're right but the
fact that they did the deal when there
were other deals that could have been
done when there were other paths they
could have taken at the quarterback
position it tells me that they came to
the conclusion that they're confident
they're more confident than they're not
confident that this is going to work out
and the fact that they only gave up the
three and a two
was just a reflection of the fact that
the eagles didn't have leverage it's not
a reflection of the fact that they have
doubts well we're only going to give you
a three and two no they're taking on
this massive contract well
not relative to patrick my homes but
they are going to pay out 40 million
over two years guaranteed fully
guaranteed so if he stinks this year
they're still stuck next year they could
cut him and and they'd get some credit
for the 15 million in guaranteed money
for next year if he signed somewhere
else but they've made the assessment and
they dug in on the compensation to the
eagles because the eagles didn't have
anyone else at the table look the the
cults were lucky that 2020 happened the
way it did for wentz
and the eagles were lucky that the cults
were where they are right now if andrew
luck doesn't retire and he's still with
indy
i don't think the eagles had anywhere
that they could have sent carson wentz
and they may have had to do the brock
osweiler trade where they either give
him away or they throw a draft pick onto
the pile to get someone to take on that
contract that's how bad it was for the
eagles
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports